what do stoics do when others behave
badly this is a great question to ask
and it does need an answer it comes up a
lot in stoic forums and groups in
workshops in random questions that get
posted on videos and it sometimes comes
in a very generic formulation like the
one that I just gave you and sometimes
it's with a great amount of precision
and specificity as the person gives
details about the bad or wrong actions
of other people that either they are
observing or they're themselves being
affected by and it's a great question in
part because what it reveals is a
mistaken understanding that sometimes
arises about stoicism
a an understanding that isn't completely
wrong but which takes a stoic idea and
then blows it up into all of stoicism
and that is of the sort of interior
withdrawal going into yourself uh
against a hostile world of both events
and other people that you feel could be
detrimental to you and it's aided by you
know little quips from you know whether
Marcus Aurelius or Seneca or Epictetus
you know for example saying you're not
being insulted unless you choose to view
yourself as being insulted nobody can
really harm you the whole notion of the
Interior Citadel and while there's some
truth to that that's not the totality of
stoicism what is the genuine stoic
approach to seeing bad or wrong or
irrational actions being done by other
people there's really three main parts
to it you can could say two or three
depending on how things are being
directed because it could be directed at
um you know the environment or animals
people you don't know the world in
general the bad actions it could be uh
directed towards beings that you feel
some sort of identification or concern
or care for remember that stoicism holds
that we are social communal animals and
that's part of our rationality and that
uh it is quite natural that we take care
of others who are not ourselves or it
could be directed at us and so in the
case of the second and third we would
have three parts to this so what are the
the general parts of a stoic approach to
seeing uh bad behavior on the part of
other people one part is classifying the
action as a bad button that takes some
doing
we also would say that you know we could
you can there's a lot of ways to
formulate this Epictetus says you can
tell yourself the action seems right or
good to that person who's doing the
wrong thing and we could say good right
or reasonable these are all closely
connected and then we can also say that
the third part is realizing that it
doesn't have to affect you negatively
unless you choose to allow it to do so
and that has to do with your own
responses and mindset so let's look at
the first one first right being stoic
does not mean avoiding judgments or not
being even judgmental it means making
judgments rightly about moral matters
which extend not just to good or bad
right or wrong but also two reasonable
and unreasonable prudence is very
important so I was saying to somebody
man that's that's really stupid what
you're doing that's a judgment and it
could in fact be
a proper judgment right if the action is
indeed a stupidly set up one or stupidly
motivated one
um stoicism does not mean saying that
nothing outside of the core of yourself
has value and you can think about the
different criteria that stoics typically
appeal to the cardinal virtues of wisdom
Justice courage and Temperance and the
corresponding vices provides moral
criteria to say that something is good
or bad right and a person has virtues or
vices or behaves virtuously or viciously
whether
um their actions whether their mindset
is in accordance with nature understood
in its full sense to include a properly
developed human nature or whether
they're out of a chord or against nature
that's another main criteria another
absolutely Central criteria the notion
of it can be trained translated Duty or
appropriate actions
this is really Central to stoicism as
well and to be a stoic doesn't mean to
stop using those criteria or to only
apply them to yourself and you know the
stoics will say that being bad or doing
bad actions Behaving Badly is bad for
the person who does them but that
doesn't mean that it's not bad for other
people if you're bullying somebody
because you are insecure and you need a
Target that person that you're bullying
is being negatively affected by it even
if it's just in terms of you know losing
money or social status they're probably
not a stoic and you're probably harming
them psychologically right and perhaps
creating More Bullies as a result and a
stoic should have no problem actually
saying that that's the case in the
second part
saying that you know the person who's
Behaving Badly is doing so because that
course of action appears to be right or
reasonable or good to them you know one
of the things that we want to think
about our our emotional reactions and
the thoughts that they stem from so
Epictetus is a great example in this as
is Seneca who's got an entire work on
this emotion anger is a very common
response to seeing people behaving badly
and it's not a good thing from a stoic
perspective it stems from our own
insecurity our own mistaken conceptions
of things and so you know we want to
avoid anger and other excessive emotions
Epictetus actually does talk about uh an
emotion that in Greek is a Laos which is
often translated as pity we could also
translate it with a word that we like
more these days because pity has a
pejorative connotation compassion right
it's you can feel compassion towards
this poor a bastard who is so screwed up
in their you know thoughts and emotional
structures and habits and assumptions
that they get basic things wrong in this
fear of morality and action and think
that they're doing the right thing when
they're doing the wrong thing right and
sometimes these Rights and Wrongs can
have several different levels and
there's nothing that says as a stoic you
can't try to persuade somebody that
their course of action is wrong you can
even try to compel them to do the right
thing that's probably going to be
unsuccessful you can inform them you can
exhort them you can do all sorts of
things and you can also Shield people
who are going to be negatively affected
there's nothing in stoicism that says
that you shouldn't do that and actually
there's good reason to think that you
ought to do those sorts of things when
you're seeing somebody on the loose with
a whole bunch of wrong-headed ideas in
their head leading to bad behavior
coming to the last thing so when it's
affecting you or somebody that you're
close to that you identify with that you
care about you have a choice about how
you allow these things to affect you and
whether you do allow them to affect you
in the core of who you are some of the
stoics call this the ruling part the
hegemony cone in Greek some like
Epictetus will talk in terms of Prior
racist The Faculty of choice also
translated in a variety of other ways
like choice or moral character various
other things but the the idea is that
you use that part of yourself to decide
how that part of yourself is going to be
affected so if you're going to let
yourself get bent out of shape as Seneca
points out every time that somebody does
something bad boy are you gonna be an
upset person right
um and it doesn't mean by the way that
people can't affect us in all sorts of
externals from our bodies to our social
status to our money and income and
wealth
um our relationships somebody can spread
gossip about us and you know a
friendship winds up being destroyed in
the process all of that is true we are
we are vulnerable to those sorts of
things it's just that those from the
stoic perspective don't have the kind of
value that being a virtuous or vicious
person does
um we're not impervious and we shouldn't
pretend that we are because you know
we're not fully developed we're not
sages but we can say this and I'll close
with this when we see somebody Behaving
Badly that provides us whether it's
affecting us directly or not with an
opportunity for reflection and for
thinking about our own choices and
behavior and thereby for growth and
development a along the path that the
stoics sketch out so as Epictetus will
tell us an entire chapter everything
that we encounter can actually be turned
to good for ourselves and that includes
the bad behavior that we observe on the
part of other people